there it is that's hard to get i don't
know if your camera is fast enough to
catch that
i'll i'll do it until you cry uncle
they
go
so for many people
me in particular viscerally this is as
close to a random phenomena as i as i
know and yet you can think about it if
you knew when the coin leaves your thumb
if you knew how fast it was traveling
and if you knew how many times a second
it was turning over newton tells you if
you know the speed how long it takes to
come down and if you know how fast it's
turning you know whether it'll come up
heads or tails coin tossing is a
deterministic process you know what's
random about it first of all
let's try doing the let's try doing a
little of the math of tossing a coin say
i'm going to say feet per second i know
that's unpopular and here's
revolutions per second so a dot on this
plane
is a coin toss right a dot on this plane
is how fast it's going
and how many times a second is it
turning so for example a dot here near
the access
so the speed is high
but the
revolutions per second is is is not so
much so that means
it
it's going up like a pizza
you know it's kind of doing this and not
really turning over if it's close enough
it might be just you know kind of slowly
turning so it might be that it doesn't
turn over at all
similarly a dot here very near the axis
up here
is a coin which was thrown with a lot of
revolutions per second but very low
speed so it never gets very far
so there's a region
like this
of initial conditions where the coin
never turns over at all okay any any
place in here the coin never turns over
at all there's some region and we could
figure out what this curve is is just
you know it's it's first course in
physics and then there's a region where
the coin turns over once
you know initial conditions here the
coin just turns over once and then
there's a third region where the coin
turns over twice
and then there's a fourth region where
the coin doesn't you know turns over
three times which is the same as turning
over once and these regions alternate
when you do the math what you find is
these regions get closer and closer
together so that small changes in
initial conditions make for the
difference between heads and tails and
for most of us that's what makes coin
tossing random
now you can ask when real people flip
real coins
where are we on this picture i want to
know how fast is the coin going when it
leaves my hand is it going five miles an
hour is it going 20 miles an hour is it
going 40 miles an hour it makes a
difference and um so i got a friend with
a stopwatch and i went one two three
flip one two three flip and uh we got
sort of synchronized and so he could
tell how long it took the coin to come
down and from that i could tell how fast
it was going now
it took three hours to get that data if
you think about it
okay to get the data about how how fast
is the coin turning i had a good
research idea which is the following
i took a coin and i took a piece of
dental floss you know the tape type
dental floss about three feet long like
that
and then i flipped the coin up
and then i could unwind the dental floss
to see how many times it had turned
until it was flat again
the floss twists around and
now it's true that a coin flipping in
the air with a piece of dental floss is
different than a coin just flipping in
the air unimpeded so
as with any measurement process the
measuring interferes with
randomness but okay you hope it's a
third order effect
based on those kinds of experiments and
a lot more of that i know where we are
on this picture and what was funny is
how fast the coins go a typical coin
flip
lasts comes up in less about half a
second and when you translate that that
means the coin's going up and back about
five and a half miles an hour that's how
fast this coin is traveling
and now i have to say where we are on
this picture this this this dot um
where where we are in this picture is
about is is is about five
and this is you know one and in the
units of this picture five and a half
miles an hour
comes down to very very close to zero
but the revolutions per second were 40
units up in the picture so this picture
says nothing about real coins but the
math behind the picture tells you how
serrated you are
up up there where you can't see
and um and it it seems to be true that
coins the way we when we flip them are
are fair to
you know two decimal places but not to
three it's not perfectly 50 50 right
in work with susan holmes and richard
montgomery we showed that coins the way
real people flip them
it's about 0.51 so 1 in 100 off and it's
not 0.51 to heads or tails it's 0.51
that it comes up
the way it started
that is if you started heads up it
spends more time heads up just and this
is and i don't care how hard you flip
the coin you can flip it to the moon
that bias is uh it's a provable stable
stable bias and it's again not a
i think or from experiments this is you
know it's a theorem when real coins flip
when we get your high speed camera
you'll be able to see that they don't
turn through their axis of symmetry in
that way
through this plane they process and they
do pretty complicated things uh and
and because of the procession it's not
just a simple
you know two parameter business
the the real analysis of flipping a coin
it's 12 parameters actually describing a
moving coin is a 12 dimensional problem
it's not something i can draw a picture
of we did the analysis in the 12
dimensional space
and
put in
some data from real people flipping real
coins we had to measure
the distribution of angular momentum
when real people flipped real coins and
that was quite challenging but we did it
and
and so
based on all of that analysis when
people when you flip a coin it's about
.51 to come up the way it started so
it's better if you see its heads it's
better to guess heads
it is also true that if you
take a coin out of your pocket or jiggle
it in your hands that probably makes the
start random and then physically
flipping a coin won't destroy that
randomness it's not as if the coins have
a predilection to kind of favor heads
when they come
this video was made at the mathematical
sciences research institute now you
might be wondering is it more fair to
catch the coin or let it drop to the
ground
you also might be wondering is it more
fair just to spin a coin on a surface
rather than tossing it through the air
in the first place well professor
diaconus has discussed both of these
with us and depending on when you're
watching this that video is coming very
soon or maybe it's already uploaded so
check those out and thanks for watching